who would you say the best president
we've had in the last hundred years
the best president we had in the last 30
years
i'd say barack obama barack obama who
else would you say
huh who else outside of brock
you know i don't have to tell you these
things you know this is bad
you know something these are ridiculous
questions this
what is my favorite movie what is my
favorite novel or whatever
i don't answer questions like this i
don't tell you what my favorite novel is
or my favorite movie i don't have to
tell you what my favorite get a
disclaimer saying we can't ask questions
on movies or things like this
so we were just told let's do an
interview with questions right is that
kind of what it was
so you said barack obama is your
favorite president fair enough let's
just go with that
barack obama is your favorite president
here's what barack obama said
february 10 2014 as one of our founding
fathers
the person who drafted our declaration
of independence
somebody who not only was an
extraordinary political leader but also
one of our great scientific and
cultural leaders thomas jefferson
represents
what's best in america do you agree with
barack obama
no i don't i don't think owning slavery
represents what's best in america
running slaves
i think to go back and to assume a time
where every one of our parents or
lineage is linked to either being a
slave owner or a slave
this includes me i'm a syrian and
armenian
so i'm sure you're familiar with the
assyrian and the armenian genocide
yes okay so i can go back and say it's
not fair to do this
and sure i can ask for a lot of things
but that's history
so if america wants to put a statue up i
don't see an issue with that i don't
know why you see an issue with that
well and you haven't been listening to
me because i've explained it i have been
but you haven't answered a lot of
questions
and and maybe it's safer to go to a
place where
you give them the questions to ask you
where the interview cannot ask you any
question
you should have told me upfront these
are 98 questions you can't ask
we wouldn't have done this interview but
if you agree to the interview
you don't want to do the interview
that's good let's just send it
if you agree to the interview the part
of interview is answering questions
you didn't tell us but i don't have to i
don't have to answer these
pity patterns questions
and you know what i'm not going to do it
i'm not going to answer your
nickname questions like who's asking me
who's my favorite
place yes because your favorite
president said
because your favorite president said
thomas jefferson
represents what's best in america that's
why
that's what you're doing you know what
you're doing you know what you're doing
what am i doing you don't like the fact
that i wrote that article for the new
yorker no no i i actually love
what you want to do with your videos
what you want to do is pick a fight with
me
absolutely not i watch every single one
of your videos and let me tell you what
was beautiful about the videos that you
have
every single one of the interviews
you've done i watched it was emotional
to see you
and to see you and i believe the
gentleman's name is shannon
lanier it was beautiful seeing the two
of you guys together
it was beautiful seeing you bringing a
family together it was beautiful seeing
you taking there to history together
it was a wonderful thing to do because
that's how you unify that's what we need
in america
that's something where it gets me
emotional to sit there and watch and say
i love this we need more of this
so you before you jump to conclusion and
judge this guy interviewing you
you have to understand that this guy was
inspired by what you did
and he's asking you basic questions to
see where you are
with why the statue is you can't answer
questions
i can answer questions i answered your
questions
why are you thinking why i think we're
going to take down the statue of
thomas jefferson yeah then i asked you
some other basic questions you refused
to answer but basic questions like who's
my favorite president yes
people ask those questions that's a
that's a baloney question
it's that it's for you to say you can
say that yes i can say that
and you asked me what you asked me what
what what what country i believe is the
best and i answered it to you
i think that's a bologna question
you asked me what was what i what did
you ask me what is my favorite what
country do you believe is the greatest
who i think is the greatest country in
the world
you know you can't answer that can you
yeah i did say it what is it ask ask the
guy you're in the studio with i asked
what
yeah i'm interviewing you not them
what what i'm asking you i'm not
interviewing these guys
no i know you're not you well if you
can't remember what my answer was
maybe one of the guys in your studio can
remember the answer and the follow-up
question was why do you think america is
the greatest country how can't you
answer that question
i did what was it i said because i said
it is
so that's your answer that's my answer
what an incredible answer because you
said
so if you got millions of 20 year olds
that are watching in america
who are on your side hoping to learn
from you they're hoping somebody with
your level of wisdom can teach them
why is america such a great country
because i
said it is that's all it is okay